a seismic by-election victory for the
liberal democrats
he wants you to think the blue wall the
tory heartlands
could become a yellow brick road how did
the political weather in a seat on the
chilton's doorstep change
quite so sharply catching almost
everyone unawares
i think it was probably hs2
that has really upset me
big time it was more about getting the
tories out and
they've had a strong supporting care for
a long time but we want to see change
that will actually impact the community
um i suppose it was just just a tactical
vote really i felt like it was kind of
the only the only option available to me
the liberal democrat leader claims
voters can be persuaded to turn their
backs on tories elsewhere in england
judging by today's result
this is one of our best ever by-election
results
and i think it puts into play dozens of
conservative uh
concessions for the liberal catch in the
south of england so the blue wall
uh is what people should be talking
about everyone's focused on the red
world the north
uh there's the rear flank of
conservatives and it's the liberal
democrats attacking that blue wall
dana westminster mps didn't see this
coming
the conventional wisdom was wrong again
that is why it's so painful for the
conservatives
and it's gonna start conversations that
they didn't want to have
about whether or not boris johnson has
become a bit complacent
whether or not he's taking elements of
his electoral coalition
for granted is there a shift in the way
britain is voting
the prime minister trying to calm nerves
by claiming this is a one-off
it's a bit peculiar a bit bizarre uh to
i i won london twice i think i was
elected in henley
uh twice and and uh you know we just
last
month we uh we we had gaines in
basildon and maidstone in beijing stoke
and
uh all all over the place so you know we
are a great one-nation party
but one formatory cabinet minister who
held the adjacent seat says local issues
can
cause national headaches i think there
is something
broader something wider that is going on
here which is the sense that in
many home counties constituencies uh
prosperous areas highly educated
senior business people there is
a softness to the conservative vote
that is that is apparent which makes the
conservatives vulnerable
today the liberal democrats created an
anti-tory majority
but boris johnson will be safe until
labour shows
it can do the same sam coates sky news
in cheshire and ambition